How long and at what temperature does a sauna provide detoxing but not weight loss?
Well, a sauna is not in itself, you know, attempting to help with weight loss.
A person is using a sauna to sweat, so you're using a sauna to sweat.
Now, cancer patients will say I'm using a sauna, a sauna also to try to increase my internal
body temperature because if I do increase my internal body temperature, even a few degrees
that can make an environment that's less stable for cancer cells and if I die, so yes, so
so does our great, so does one of my favorite therapies.
So no, what temperature do you do it?
You typically do it at 140 degrees, some people do higher degrees and your goal is that you
work towards stay in there 20 to 30 minutes.
Now some people can start with a sauna and you can only be in there for three minutes and
you can't do it anymore, you have to get out personally with me, with me.
I have a difficult time going in a full body sauna.
I feel with my nasal poly issue that I feel like I have a hard time breathing.
That's what I like.
The sauna is where your head is out, those are the ones that we sell and other people sell
where your head is out.
I don't feel claustrophobic, I don't feel like I have breathing issues.
It increases the body temperature and helps me sweat just as much, but I still, even at
that, when I first started using a sauna, I could only do it for about maybe 10 minutes
and I started sweating right away, but I've just done it, so I guess that's easy for
me.
Some people take some multiple times to do a sauna before they even start sweating.
The idea of a sauna is that you're detoxing through your skin and you're taking pressure off
of your liver and the other idea is to increase your body temperature.
If you're fighting, you're losing weight in a sauna, excuse me, is you've got to be
rehydrated.
Make sure you're rehydrated.
You know what?
You will.
You know, when you're sweaty, you're losing electrolytes too and you don't want to cause dehydration.